this meeting is
hi everybody well it's nice to see so
many names popping up
um welcome to this session on the cost
of living crisis just so that everybody
is aware the session is being recorded
so that it can be played back but just
to confirm that people's identity will
be kept confidential so
um that you know people's identity won't
be given out of this session the idea of
the session it's only an hour so we
haven't got a lot of time and we have
got some pre-post questions already so
we're going to try and get for as many
questions as we can so like I said we've
got the pre-posed questions but we've
also got
um residents and and anybody on the call
today can pose a question to us and
we'll do our best to answer them as
quickly and as effectively as we can so
by way of introduction I'm Tracy Lilly
I'm the director for communities and
health for Rochford and Brentwood and
I'll be kind of hosting the session this
evening I won't try to try not to say
too much
but um we've got a fantastic panel of
experts dare I say and hopefully we'll
be able to answer all the questions you
have so I'm going to go around the
virtual room and get the panel members
to introduce yourself as they are on my
screen so councilor Belton would you
like to introduce yourself
thank you so I'm councilor Danielle
Belton I'm the portfolio holder for
climate and economy
thank you very much councilor Williams
thank you Tracy I'm councilor Arthur
Williams and portfolio holder for
communities and health thank you
fabulous thank you Kathy
hi I'm Kathy cantisch and I'm the chief
executive for Citizens advice South
Essex
and
thank you my name's Anne Scott and I'm
the Essex development manager at the
Federation of small businesses
and definitely last but not least
councilor Simon Wootton
thank you Tracy good evening everyone
I'm Council Simon Morton leader of
Rochford District Council
fantastic but as I said at the beginning
of this session we've had some Advanced
questions so I think we'll start with
those to give people the kind of
time to think of a question they might
want to ask and put it in in the chat
and would like I said we'll do our very
very best to answer as many questions as
we can our Focus today is about
responding to the cost of living crisis
that we're all experiencing whether
you're a resident a business
um or working for the local Authority
we're all in this together so the first
question that we have is is quite a long
question but I'll read it out and then
I'll hand over to the panel members to
answer so the first question is so many
residents have inefficient heating
systems this also increases climate
change due to the unnecessary high level
of greenhouse gases from gas central
heating boilers there are many ways to
ease the cost of living crisis and
keeping the districts as low emission
Zone how do you how do you propose I
think that should be that the district
remains harmonious between the cost of
living and climate change
now I think I'll hand over to councilor
Belton to respond to that question
thanks thanks Tracy yeah it's quite
right
um Heating and insulation is a is a
really big one when it comes to reducing
fuel costs and obviously helping the
climate
at the moment there are multiple grants
available and they are for social
housing residents for businesses and
also for homeowners and private tenants
so I will share a link in the chat so
that people have access to that
information but essentially we have eco4
which can do everything it can get you
New Heating insulation solar panels
um Sanctuary housing are working on the
social decarbonization for a lot of
their properties in the area which again
is going for that real fuel um whole
home retrofit to reduce costs for their
residents
and in the new year there's a grant
coming out called Eco plus which
basically fills the Gap so all those
people that are not in receipt of
benefits that own their home but can't
quite afford what needs to be invested
in their property to bring their fuel
costs down there's a grant coming out
that will support them now what Rochford
are doing to support that is one
signpost in to make sure people know how
they can find that information and how
they can apply for those grants and
they're also working with Essex County
Council on a specific scheme called lad
which again it's local area delivery and
it's about supporting local residents
and to improve their properties so
ultimately it's really important and it
is a really quick way to reduce costs
but I implore everybody to look for the
grants that are available before they
put their hand in their pockets because
every penny is going to count over the
winter months
yeah no that's brilliant thanks
councilor Belton that's a really good
response and it is really difficult and
what I would add to that is one of the
things that
um councilor Orton was very keen on us
doing as a local Authority is being
there to act as the kind of conduit and
enabler I suppose in a sense to the the
cost of living crisis because it's not
ours to solve but what we've tried to do
is put as much information on our web
pages as we can so there is a cost of
living web page that you can access and
I'm sure that will come up in the group
chat and I would urge people to go to
that um because there's lots of and it's
not just about what we're doing it's
about what all our partners are doing
and all of the support that's out there
so I think that's a really key thing to
do just go and have a look on our
website and there's lots of information
there as well so I hope that answers the
question for the person that posed it I
feel like it did but we'll move on to
the next question
and this is one for the leader actually
and it's will the leader pledge to give
additional support to those District
residents in most need above and beyond
already confirmed what's already been
confirmed by the government or Essex
County Council so councilor Walton over
to you for that one thank you very much
indeed Tracy um before I actually go to
that specific question what I really
wanted to do was say that much earlier
this year we were aware of the Dreadful
events in Ukraine and very quickly we
were aware that there was going to be
fuel shortages it is that that has
actually fed the cost of living crisis
certainly in the early stages
um in terms of driving prices of fuel up
and like me everyone will have been
paying of the order of two pounds a
liter just a few months ago for their
fuel which was a huge increase in itself
compared with 130 140 that we were used
to paying for quite a few years so that
drove a lot of the inflationary factors
because clearly most businesses are
dependent on fuel and they have to pass
on uh and recover those costs through
the goods that they produce and in turn
that feeds inflation and by feeding
inflation
unfortunately one of the ways the bank
of England deal with that is to put up
mortgage rates so from a point of view
of residence that is just a double
whammy that two of their major cost
factors immediately go up
I became very acutely aware in the very
early spring that this was going to be a
real issue for our residents and our
businesses in the district
and I set about at that time saying that
I wanted Rochford District Council to be
at the Forefront of what it could do for
its residents
unfortunately and as much as I would
like to go into this Magic Money Tree
Roger Council does not in itself have
funds that it can distribute Rochford
Council as part of the tier of local
government that is it is in is there to
provide services for residents and
businesses in an efficient and economic
fashion
so I'd want to temper expectation and
perhaps disappoint some people on this
call that we will not be able to be
solving everyone's personal needs in
terms of handing out money
I'd like to be able to say that we can
but I really want do want to temper
expectation what we can do is to play
our part in bringing Partners together
and address the issues that are facing
our residents through signposting
through working with Partners the
citizens advice the business the various
business organizations Federation of
small businesses and officers within our
Authority so by way of introduction I'm
really pleased that tonight gives just
one strand of an opportunity to make
residents aware of what we're doing as
an authority temper expectations in what
we can do but also say that there are so
many organizations out there who can
give practical help
um but part of this I'm afraid and it
applies to all of us is also taking a
certain amount of personal
responsibility for making sure that for
example we don't waste energy in our
houses we eat only those rooms that we
actually need to eat and we are
um doing the sensible things to help
ourselves but in terms of the question
itself really good question and I've
already alluded to the fact that the
council itself is not in a position to
give additional support just across the
board
um that isn't what we can do
um but we have to recognize that
Rochford District Council is a business
like any business it is subject to
inflationary costs to deliver the
services and the people that we work
with both in sourced and outsourced
providers have their cost pressures so
we as a council are subject to increases
of the order of between 10 and 20
percent
set that against the fact that we are
only permitted to increase our council
tax by a maximum of three percent and
that's certainly not an announcement
because that decision will be taken
early in the new year
um we uh um you can see that the maths
of cost of living or the
um increase current increase of cost of
living around 10 percent and we can only
increase out costs you can see that as a
council we Face the same issues that
residents and businesses do in the
district
our fuel is going up
our staffing costs are going up
our heating costs and all these things
so to just give across the board
commitment that we will hand out loads
of money would just be creating false
expectation
but what I do hope to do in the budget
which we will announce in February March
of next year is I do hope that we can
set aside an amount of money to give
target support to those most in need
but uh I hope that answers the question
brilliant thank you councilor Orton I
think it might be worth just mentioning
I'm very focused as the as the Director
of community
about getting the support to Residents
and those that need our business and
everybody else at the point they need it
so like I said before and you'll keep
hearing this from me it's not about what
we can do it's about what we can do to
enable that support to happen and what
I've said to people is this brings a
whole new
um
group if you like of vulnerable people
to the table this cost of living crisis
because there are those that are
vulnerable in social housing and on
benefits already but actually people in
this room will be vulnerable for the
first time in their lives because they
won't have experienced money troubles
before and we're all experiencing it and
I'm experiencing it myself so we do
remain focused on getting the support
out there I promise you and there's lots
of things that we're doing I have to
report back to Executive every month and
the stuff that that we're doing in with
our partners we've got a very very very
strong partnership in Rochford fantastic
organizations not just cab and the
Federation small businesses we've got
Hub at the mega Center we've got rabs
we've got all sorts of different
agencies out there that are really best
place to help but I'm going to save the
next point I was going to say because I
will use that a next question
um if I can come back just there please
Tracy and say this was one of the things
as a council we recognize we need to do
is to bring it back to our monthly
public meeting which is our executive to
have an update report every month on
what we're doing the changes so that
people can see that it's right at the
Forefront of our thinking on a
day-to-day basis and every month we
review what we have done and what we
think we might be able to do update all
our information so thanks for making
that point no problem at all the next
question was a fantastic question and it
actually caused a lot of um concern for
us because it's it's something that's
come up before and it's a really really
really good question so this person has
asked they'd like to know if anyone is
actually looking into the 400 pound
energy grant for Park home residents
um this person is
um Hockley Park she they live on Hockley
Park which is owned by Tim Dean Parks
they read their meter and then they send
the bill for them to pay so they don't
deal with the Energy company directly
and Ting Dean have written to them to
say that they won't be passing on the
grant
um so where do they get it from is the
question I'll go to councilor Belton and
then I'll go to Kathy after that if
that's okay
foreign
thank you I mean to be honest this is
something that's come up a couple of
times from residents that live on Park
Homes because we do have a fair few
within the the district and it's a
challenging one because it's sort of
it's a bit of a loophole or it seemed to
be a bit of a loophole so I'm hoping
citizens advice may be able to share a
bit more information because I know it
is something that's been concerning
residents and I certainly hadn't been
able to get an answer previously
um because they fall outside of the
landlord situation and they don't have
the direct connection with the utility
companies so I'm hoping Kathy might be
able to shed some light that we can
share with residents on those park homes
no pressure Kathy okay thank you both
um so yes there are about five park
homes in Rochford District so there's a
lot of people living in um Park Homes
um the what the government have done is
they have introduced this 400 pounds for
every household off your energy bills so
for most households that would mean that
you get it over a period between October
March next year a certain amount of each
month and you shouldn't have to do
anything at all it should be applied
automatically but for Park Homes it's
different which can seem really unfair
what the government have done is they've
passed a new act it's called the
pass-through requirements and what they
think any fit means is the
intermediaries so people who own for
example the park homes site should pass
on the discount 400 pounds to the park
home residence
but if they choose not to then they
should write to each resident and
explain why they're not passing it on
and there can be some reasons why
so once I've done that if the resident
is unhappy with that letter or they
don't receive a letter then there are
template letters on gov.uk and we'll put
the link in the chat that you can use to
challenge that and to request that
information
if once you've got that information
you're still not happy with either the
amount being passed on or there's
nothing being passed on
you can challenge it further but it's a
civil matter it's a civil legal matter
and what that means is that you need to
take small claims call Action and of
course that can be quite scary for
people so sentence advice is here to
help you if at any point in that process
you need support
um small claimsical action does come
with an initial cost it's a nominal
amount depends on the amount you're
claiming
um and at this stage because this is all
relatively new we haven't got anything
set down in uh that has gone to the
court to set a precedent
so we're waiting really for the first
case to go and see what happens
um but as I say it's a difficult
situation it can seem very unfair but a
sense of us is here to help you so if
any point in that you struggle we'll
also put the website in the chat
about how to contact us we're currently
opening Rochford and Riley for
face-to-face services but you can also
contact us on the phone and by email as
well
I hope that answers a little bit and
provide some reassurance
a fantastic Cafe you never fail to
deliver it is a really difficult
question but it felt like as as tough as
it is there is some support out there so
I would urge people to to get in contact
with citizen advice and get that support
that they need if they're if they are
fearful about taking that next step and
I'd like to jump to this next question
because I feel like it's quite pertinent
and it's how can I help people in my
community who are finding this crisis
really tough
and it's like I've said before
everybody's finding this really really
tough really tough and what I would say
one of the things that's come up through
our working group that we've established
and it's attended by over 50 Partners is
that all of those groups and some of
them I've mentioned and Kathy is sitting
here today the way that you can help and
I'll keep saying this is volunteer
volunteer volunteer because one of the
things that
we're conscious of is we are you know
very great at signposting and we'll sign
post you to cab and we'll sign poetry to
other agencies but actually they rely on
volunteers so the best way to do it is
look out for your elderly and vulnerable
in your community but volunteer
volunteer volunteer and I'll bring Kathy
in on that question as well if you don't
mind Kathy yeah that's fine completely
agreeing would Echo everything Tracy has
just said so since advice and all of the
voluntary sector are actively recruiting
volunteers if you feel that you've got
any time that you can give up to help
your local community then we'd love to
see you and the way you can apply is
through our website which is now in the
chat but as I say you can go to a lot of
the other voluntary sectors while I
can't monopolize all of it and so there
are lots of voluntary sector
organizations out there that would love
to see more and more volunteers because
the more volunteers we've got the more
people we can help support especially
over what is going to be quite a tough
winter for everybody so thank you
again that's brilliant Kathy and like I
said before you know there's Hub at the
mega Center and I think we'll put all
the links up and there's rabs as well so
there's lots of of ways that you can
volunteer and don't be fearful about
volunteering because it's whatever time
you have they'll gratefully take it from
you so I think that's a really good way
of doing it
um I'm conscious that we have the
Federation of small businesses here so
I'll ask the the poses question and I'll
go over to you Anne what support is
there for business owners who are
feeling stressed and anxious and I think
that's really key and what you know is
really important and it is posed in
another question that we've had which
I'll read in a little bit
the people that are running those
businesses in our local community are
our residents as well so it's it's a
really important question but I'll hand
over to Anne if you don't mind then
thank you so the Federation of small
businesses represents around about 4 000
small businesses here in Essex and
across the UK 140 000 small businesses
they're facing astronomical
um headwinds at the moment soaring costs
falling revenues they're getting it from
all angles so it doesn't surprise me
actually that you've had that question
around small business owners feeling
very kind of stressed and anxious not
only are they facing the cost of doing
business crisis that they're facing the
cost of living crisis as well in in
their home lives
I would say that a recent report really
highlights the the level of anxiety at
the moment and when we
um surveyed our members one in four told
us that they plan to close downsize or
restructure if they don't get any more
support past April with energy bills I
think that really highlights the the
scale of the issue here
I'd say that the first Port of Call if
you're a small business owner looking
for advice and support is actually the
economic development team at Rochford
District Council they're absolutely
fantastic and I believe there is a great
portal on your cost of living Hub in
relation to business support and advice
it would be remiss of me uh working for
the FSB not to mention
um ourselves as a place where small
businesses can go obviously we
we've been around for 40 years now and
we are one of the largest business
support organizations and you may not
know this we were actually born out of a
lobbying organization someone who
disagreed with the increase in National
Insurance and we stayed true to our
Roots uh today we still very much Lobby
on behalf of all of our members and
small businesses in general to make sure
that the government are making those
changes that are going to help stimulate
the economy
you may have heard recently actually the
the chancellor name checked us in
relation to business rates and the
freezing of business rights that's
something we brought before very hard on
in in recent months and over the next
couple of months we'll be doing lots of
work with uh bays and the treasury on on
energy bills
but alongside the lobbying
um we offer a raft of benefits and
services to our members from 177 pounds
a year and I'm not going to go through
them all because a there's too many to
mention in this webinar but B this isn't
a plug for the FSB and to try to get
people to to sign up but there's one in
particular that's very helpful and
that's our legal Hub where you can get
thousands and thousands of documents
um all templates designed to help you
design contracts and write letters if
for example you're facing late payments
we also have a 24 7 helpline number and
legal claims are covered up to 100
000 pounds so it's some quite incredible
benefits there for our members
but outside of the membership we also
offer quite an incredible amount of free
resources reports webinars and
networking sessions and they're actually
available for free for non-members as
well as members so I definitely check
out the website we've got everything on
there from sustainability to marketing
it really is a wealth of information
outside of the ffb I just want to touch
on some other business support
organizations because we are not the
only one
um in particular I want to mention
backing Essex business who's funded by
Essex County Council and the growth hubs
who are funded by the local Enterprise
Partnerships now they offer a range of
free advice training packages and
funding so definitely Google backing
Essex business and the local growth hubs
in addition to that you also have the
terms of Commerce who like us are a
membership organization and I also
wanted to give out a shout to Colby who
I believe they offer a fully funded
Business Service uh support package
commissioned by yourselves actually
providing one-to-one support for small
businesses so thankfully there is a lot
of help out there for small businesses
um
which is encouraging
um given that the current situation
we're in um so yeah thank you
thanks Anne councilor Belton
thank you if I may just add to that and
I completely endorse everything Anne
said and as a member of the FSB I can
vouch for the fact that they they offer
some fantastic support
um for small businesses
um just a couple of other things that
the council issue pretty much weekly a
tell me more bulletin and it is
extremely useful I urge everybody to
sign up residents and businesses because
you can select the things that are
important to you and it it really
highlights what's available in the area
and it brings that signposting right to
your inbox so I really encourage people
to to go on the website and sign up to
that and just as well from a business
point of view in a very localized way
we're lucky to have the Hockley Rayleigh
and Rochford chamber of Trades and the
three of them work very closely together
the three chambers
but it's a really nice environment for
local businesses that work in the exact
same area and geographically to talk to
each other to share experiences and to
help one another and because sometimes a
problem shared is a problem halved as
they say and that's no different in
business than it is in any other sector
of life so I really encourage people to
reach out to the chambers because
they're a great group of people and
they're very very local as well as all
the other
um advice that Ann gave
perfect thank you trying to spread it
across residents business and everybody
else we'll go to this next question
which is other than just signposting
residents to places for support what are
you actually doing as a district council
to help the with the cost of living
crisis not businesses but residents also
and I'll direct that to councilor
Wootton as leader thank you Tracy
um as I alluded to earlier uh the
council is not in a position nor should
it be in a position to have vast sums of
money to distribute in situations like
this this is not the responsibility of
local government at our level but I
would like to remind everyone that there
has been a significant level of central
funding notwithstanding
um the what I think is pretty appalling
situation affecting Park home owners
that was alluded to earlier and
incidentally on that point I am quite
happy as leader of this authority to
write a letter to the owners of these
Park home sites disapproving of the uh
the fact that they're not passing this
money onto their residence uh you know
it's frankly just not good enough so if
I can be another wait to that argument
I'm more than happy to do that because I
think it's pretty important
um but that's another story but
um
I think other than just signposting I
I've got to be very careful on that
point because I think what we are doing
is huge
um we are pulling together Partners who
want to help through Partners who are on
this call tonight the various Faith
groups County Council we're working with
government
um but I think signposting is hugely
hugely important and so I'm not quite
sure what else we are expected to do
um I would talk about the um the warm
hubs we made a provision available a
month or two ago for warm hubs and that
enables any organization to bid for up
to 500 pounds from Rochford District
Council to provide a warm Hub uh so uh
warm space for for residents so I would
urge any organization to again go on to
our website and have a look at the the
bidding process for that uh because well
actually what we're doing as I also said
earlier I would like to think that as we
get towards our budget we can look to
see whether or not we can Target uh some
money towards those people who are
hard-pressed but through a means by
which we actually get it to people
genuinely in um in in hardship there are
a number of uh hardship schemes at the
present time I was talking to our
revenues and benefits people a little
earlier today
um on this very point to make sure that
we make everyone aware of all the
schemes that there are already out there
but certainly I would like to do more
from Roger District Council to Target
those people but I can say uh bluntly
that there will not be an across the
board large sum of money coming to any
of us who live in the district I want it
to be targeted and I want it to reach
the right places thank you Tracy thank
you Council Lawton
um and it's gone up in the in the chat
that I can see around the Hub at the
mega Center and and everything that
they're doing
um but I won't say anymore because I'm
going to hand over to councilor Williams
yes thank you Tracy um regarding the
warm hubs
um this has been being
um
sorted by ravs at the moment there's
about seven groups that are benefiting
from this we still have some more money
available at the moment Rodger District
Council have made a considerable amount
of money available it's there are no
difficult forms to fill in it's just an
email to ravs telling them who you are
what you're requesting and how much
you're requesting on what for it's as
simple as that so there is something out
there thank you
perfect thank you Council Williams
the next question because I'm very
conscious of time so we want to get
through as many as possible
um and we've touched on the answer to
this question already but it's been
posed so I will raise it
um and this is another question to the
leader will you be raising the council
tax as high as possible due to the cost
of living crisis
and councils may be struggling
that's over to you councilor Walton
thank you Tracy um yeah we've talked
about council tax a fair bit it is a
large bill that comes through many
residence letterboxes uh around uh March
time
um now I do want to say that the
proportion of council tax that Rochford
District Council gets is relatively
small because we are the collection
Authority for Essex County Council who
have the lion chair of council tax uh
the police fire and crime commissioner
who sets a precept for for
um both police policing in our County
and for fire the Rochford Council
precept is very small
and if I tell you that uh a three
percent increase is equivalent to seven
pound fifty on a banned D property that
puts into some sort of perspective the
actual amount in cash terms that we're
talking about
and I think it would be quite insulting
to sort of say well we'll give you that
seven pound fifty back because that's
going to go nowhere towards uh
supporting people
um which is why I said a little earlier
I would like to try and design something
which is targeted back to those people
most in need rather than the blanket
blanket approach
um
the council is struggling itself are not
going to pretend that our own budget Gap
isn't increasing as a result of the uh
of the crisis but we still have to
deliver our services in terms of
collecting waste cutting grass
um doing all the services that we do
licensing planning uh all the Myriad of
services that we do across our community
so it's tough for us as a business and
here we are trying to do our best and we
will do our best to help others at the
same time but it's a it is a conundrum
for us because we as a business are also
facing exactly the same exposure I said
it earlier I'll say it again 10 in terms
of the uh rise in the retail price index
um 10 11
we can increase our charges by a maximum
of three percent but that isn't an
announcement about what we will do on
council tax it's midi saying the
government has said last week I believe
that it would permit us to increase
council tax by up to three percent for
unitary and County council's First tier
authorities uh it's up to five percent
but that includes the
um social care precept that they they
have within their authorities we don't
uh we're a second tier Authority and uh
up to three percent is what we would be
allowed to do which as I say is
equivalent to roughly seven pound fifty
um for a Band-Aid property thank you
Tracy thank you Council I think that
answers that question
um this was another question that came
in and I have to say and I know it
probably seems odd for those that are in
the virtual room because I work for a
local Authority it resonated with me
massively and I quickly got on the phone
um to my mortgage company because my um
fixed rate ends in June and I was in a
bit of a panic and one of the things I
would say in this and I'll read the
question out in a minute it's about the
biggest advice I can give you is please
please please don't bury your head in
the sand like I said this is affecting
all of us there is no shame to be had
here there really isn't and one thing I
would say is one iPhone my mortgage
company it said we're experiencing a
large volume of calls so that goes to
show that we're all in the same boat and
we're all trying to get the information
and advice
um so this question was was it helped me
actually but it's it's really relevant
and it's is there in any help available
for families that are not in receipt of
benefits or not classed as having a low
income two working parents heavy child
care costs and a mortgage increase of
more than 50 percent
um
I I even think It Go I mean I'm a single
parent household so you know it doesn't
matter whether it's single parent or or
joint but I think I'll go over to Kathy
for that one because I know
um you're definitely going to be able to
answer this question and I'm going to
make notes
okay thank you right okay it's
challenging isn't it and there isn't as
much or it doesn't feel as if there's as
much out there for you but we've talked
already about the 400 pound that every
household gets in addition to that there
is the energy price guarantee so this is
where they they calculate on an average
use the maximum amount that would be
paid and that is worked out on a maximum
tariff which for an average youth
household maximum amount would be 2 500
pounds
for a year
it will change next April but let's
worry about that next April at the
moment it's 2 500. that doesn't mean to
say that's the maximum you or I would
pay irrelevant of how often we put the
heating on it is still based or your
charges are based on how much you use
the Tariff is what's capped at an
average household use of two and a half
thousand pound per annum
so it's still sensible to save energy
costs wherever you can and if you have a
look on the citizens of ice Essex warm
homes website and we'll put the link
again in the chat it's been in there
earlier I've seen it there are some top
tips about energy saving in there for
you
in addition I would always recommend
getting a benefit check you can do that
yourself going online there are various
benefit Checkers available
um entitled to is one of them if you
come into citizens advice then we will
do a benefit check for you as well
because you'll find that some people
particularly have got high child child
care costs may be entitled to some
support they're not aware of and so it's
always worth checking just in case
and agree completely with what Tracy
says don't bury your head in the sand
which I know is easier to say than do
isn't it but we're here to help there
are lots of organizations out there who
can help and make a sense or I've seen
they put some information in the chat
they're open there every day to help
people as well so talk to people who are
there to support you we work as a good
team of Partners all the statutory and
the voluntary sector and we are here to
try and help everybody and anybody and I
think what you're going to find is that
the people who've been just about
managing before or just about imagine
managing during the pandemic perhaps
going to be the ones who are coming to
the end of perhaps a two or a five year
six or eight mortgage and yeah the cost
could go up quite scarily so that's when
you need to be seeking some help trying
to figure out what else is there that
you're entitled to and trying to get as
much support as you can
that's perfect thanks Kathy councilor
Belton
thank you just um a couple of other
things as well because the sort of the
the people the group of people is
working people I think is sort of who
the question was poised about
um ask your employers about extra
support that's available because there
are child care support that you can get
it doesn't cost your employer or
anything they just have to sign you up
to schemes but it can save on tax
essentially also married people there
are tax savings to be had there's lots
and lots of schemes out there that exist
that none of us know about because we've
never had to consider them before but
with my employer hat on I know that
there's lots and lots of things and and
they can add up to hundreds of pounds of
savings per month especially when you're
paying child care so I would urge people
to ask your employers their employers
may not know about the schemes
themselves but they'll certainly have
access to finding out about them so
asking the questions again it's that
problem shared problem halved and
there's lots and lots of opportunity out
there that doesn't cost other people
anything
no that's perfect and that's actually
quite reassuring because it is really
really difficult and I'd again mention
our web page
um I'm obsessed about the web page
because I'm constantly Googling stuff
about the cost of living crisis and my
own personal reasons and literally every
time I find something or the officers
find something we're constantly
messaging each other can we make sure
this is on the web page if it's not
already so you know we're constantly
checking that web page to make sure that
the information is there and it is
correct so please have a look at any
partners that are actually in the
virtual room I say this all the time
have a look and if you if we've missed
something or you think something needed
to be added to it or amended in any way
let us know we're not proud because like
I said at the very beginning I keep
saying this is about making sure the
information is there and and like we've
all said tonight please please please
please don't bury your head in the sand
I think we have a tendency to do that
sometimes I've done it myself in the
past and don't do that talk to each
other we're all in the same boat and and
we will only get through this together
we saw it through the pandemic Mick and
who would have thought the pandemic hit
I mean we dealt with that and now we've
got a cost of living crisis it just
keeps giving doesn't it
um but one of the other questions that
we've had is around the support for for
businesses again and it's are there any
local networks that business owners can
tap into for support and information and
advice I know that we've touched on this
but it might be worth mentioning again
some of the the kind of networks that
are out there and I'll hand over to you
if that's okay thank you so we know that
running a small business can be
incredibly lonely at times I think
particularly at the moment with the cost
of living crisis
um it can sort of magnify how people are
feeling and actually our small business
index we recently did indicated that our
members are feeling even more
pessimistic than during the lockdowns
about the cost of living crisis so they
they really are kind of feeling that the
pinch at the moment so as you said um
and kind of sharing
um your problems and sharing best
practice and experiences can be really
quite cathartic and good for for
well-being and mental health so we run a
series of monthly virtual networking
events actually which are open to
non-members as well as members and it's
a great way to meet other small
businesses from across Essex east of
England and indeed the UK not just to
collaborate and potentially join forces
in terms of your business but sharing
best practice sharing problems so we
have an Essex one east of England's one
and a woman in Enterprise for the east
of England we've actually finished for
2022
um if you go on the FSB website look at
the events calendar you'll see all the
events we've got going on in 2023 we've
actually scaled back on our physical
events for the very reason that we've
touched on this evening you know it's
quite expensive to jump in the car and
pay for petrol so we've recognized that
and we hold a series of online virtual
networking events and I also just want
to mention very quickly we have our big
networking event on Friday the 9th of
December and that's open to everyone
across the UK last year we had over a
thousand small businesses signed up and
this year there's a chance of winning a
Dell laptop which could come in quite
handy actually but we're not the only
ones who run networking events I know
the terms of Commerce do I'm sure if you
go onto Google or Eventbrite you'll see
all the different networking events that
are on offer for businesses large and
small
perfect thank you I'm just trying to go
back over some of the questions that
have been posed in in the chat as we've
been moving through the session
um and one of the interesting questions
that's been raised is that this is
reaching 24 people including presenters
and will we have similar question and
answer sessions live at other venues I'm
not going to say what venue because it's
not really relevant
um so that people without internet can
partake one thing I would say about that
it goes back to some of the things that
we've raised before and and it's a
really good question and it comes up
time and time again about those without
internet and we have what we're
developing as a digital campaign when I
say digital I don't mean it's going to
be delivered digitally but it's around
getting a whole Suite of information
that we can get out there to our
residents in the best possible situation
so we've got lots of agencies that we
work with already
and we'll be doing lots of drop-in
sessions we're looking at potentially
using any venue that we can where we can
have sessions where people can come in
and get information and advice and use
the internet in those venues so that's
something to look out for on our website
um but that particular question was
posed to yourself councilor Watson as
leader in terms of do you think a live
session for people without the internet
is something that we would partake in
you're on mute councilor watan
thank you Tracy
um uh my answer was absolutely
um I think we should use all uh routes
that we can to get to uh residents and
businesses in the district I think this
is an excellent medium for getting to to
people because they can sit in uh
relative Comfort at home without the
need to go out and they can click on a
link and they can go on to a virtual
meeting but I think we've got to be very
careful that we don't think this is the
only means by which we communicate with
people it can be very effective a lot of
people really like it and they prefer
this medium rather than actually going
out to a meeting but let's have meetings
let's talk about it
um and um through any route now direct
set this point that not everyone is
digitally minded or wants to do stuff in
this way have a meeting in this way so
this is the first if there's a demand
for it let's go out let's let's talk to
people face to face that's what I
personally really enjoy so I welcome the
idea yeah no that's brilliant thank you
and I think I'll just reiterate the
point one other thing that they're very
passionate about is making sure that we
reach everybody and part of the digital
campaign that we're developing I think
it's in the group chat as well is around
um pocket cars that we can give to
people because one of the things that
we're very focused on is and we've built
our whole response to the cost of living
crisis around five key themes so the
information is out there and we're going
to regularly get out in whatever way we
can and that's a community groups
existing groups we've got dedicated
offices within our housing team that
offer benefits advice you've got some of
the groups mentioned tonight the Hub at
the mega Center do regular activities
there they offer warm spaces I've seen
another one
where Sanctuary are very keen to to get
involved with us in terms of the the
warm Hub so that's really good we'll
take that opportunity up but it's it's
just about making sure that residents
are aware that we're not just putting
out social media information on all of
the stuff that we send out there will be
a telephone number that you can call the
website and there's a QR code as well so
and an email address so that there's
we're offering as many ways to
communicate with us as possible so if in
doubt phone us up but I'd go back to the
original
um question around what can we do for
our community it's about actually if
something like this comes up and we saw
it fairly recently with it with a public
meeting and there wasn't not a single
person in the audience but there was a
number on the virtual platform so that
was very interesting to see and I think
we've changed because when you put these
kind of things in a particular venue not
everybody can get to that venue either
so it's just about having that constant
messaging to say that we're there we're
there to support we'll go out and we'll
meet as many people as we can and give
that information as readily as we can so
we're kind of coming to almost an end of
the session
um but I hope that's addressed a lot of
the questions one thing that as has come
up in terms of the the support what's
out there for families and stuff and
it's really key and it's nice to see
that the Hub at the maker Center are
putting stuff in the chat as well and
it's the support for families and
children in the holidays and there's
lots of stuff in the holiday period that
is for free so active Essex offer free
holiday clubs but there's also free
School meals
um and things like that for people so if
in doubt and you're not entirely sure
because I always say this to to staff
and officers that I work with if
as a member of the public if you're not
in social housing and you can't pay your
mortgage or you can't you can't pay your
energy bill
I don't think you'd be phoning the
council for that advice but we have got
that information on our website we are
monitoring the calls that we receive and
it's very very few
um people are fairly switched on and
supporting each other with the
information that they're obtaining but
there is stuff on our website so please
please please have a look at it
um but I can't see any other questions
in the in the group chat that we haven't
already answered unless anybody's got
anything specific that they wanted to to
raise
um I don't have any more questions
no
well it may be that we finish early and
everybody gets 10 minutes of their time
back
let me just double check before we
finish the session
our kids actually mention very quickly
um Rochford Council are running the
business Awards we've actually sponsored
the SME of the Year award and I believe
the deadline has been extended to the
Department of December so if there's any
small businesses out there
um or indeed large businesses who wants
to nominate themselves and get the
recognition that they deserve for the
last year then I'd recommend popping on
the Rochford District Council website
little kids are really good opportunity
to highlight and celebrate some of the
amazing things our businesses have done
in in the last year
okay that's lovely thanks Anne um I've
just been reminded of one question
um which is why can't pressure be put on
the government and off gym to stop the
daily standing charge this can equal to
nearly 350 pounds per year this charge
does not have anything to do with the
wholesale price of energy
and I don't know if that's something
that you could address councilor Wootton
in terms of what we could do from that
perspective from a local government
um I think it comes back to probably
another letter
um you know I think the more leaders of
councils that write on these things and
express their concern
um the more we can Lobby on that exactly
that sort of thing
um I have to say when I look at my own
fuel bills and you see standing charge
going up uh it frustrates me
um it's an element of the bill that I
sort of think well where's the increased
cost I know there's a a delivery
infrastructure that has to be maintained
but uh I do think at a time like this it
would be good if that element of our
bill didn't have to increase but again
it's if if one of the outcomes is for me
to write a letter uh then I'm more than
happy to do that from uh from the
council
that's great thank you yeah I mean it's
really difficult because like we we've
established this evening it's not
necessarily something that we can always
change but I hope you all feel around
the room that we are here to support you
we've we've tried to be as honest as
possible in the spirit of openness we've
I've answered the questions that have
been posed before and during the session
um so I hope you've got something from
it but what I would say is if you if
there's any unanswered questions or you
didn't feel comfortable posing a
question in this forum then please
please please contact us and we will
happily come back to you I know my team
are very passionate about supporting as
many residents and we are like I said at
the very beginning very very lucky can I
say really really lucky that we have so
many
um partners and agencies in this
District that support the residents in
the way that they do so um I'll refer
you back to our web site and I hope you
all have a lovely evening I don't think
I've got any other questions but you
always find this and cancer wouldn't put
his hand up so I'll bring him in in a
minute we get to the end and everyone
thinks oh I've got one I've got one I've
got one so we'll keep going but Council
of water
thank you very much indeed Tracy and
always you've got to know when we are
hitting the end and you're controlling
it uh tonight but certainly a number of
people have come up to me and said what
can I do on a personal basis to actually
help within my community and we see this
it's a real uh cultural issue within
Great Britain we are at our best when we
have the sort of situation that we've
got when people actually want to
volunteer and help and I can only
recommend that
um you go to the various organizations
because volunteers are appreciated in so
many areas ravs within uh the Rochford
district is the area and again there's a
signposting to their website but they
are if you like the overarching body
that know about all volunteering
Services throughout the district so it's
a plug for them but I think you know
when we look on the other side of the
equation of people actually wanting to
go out and be practically helpful to
people who are less fortunate
um you know I think that really is the
terrific spirit that we have certainly
here in Rochford uh certainly here in in
Great Britain uh it's wonderful when we
see people coming together and wanting
to help I'm not quite sure whether
you've got any more questions but I'm
going to say my closing comments now and
then you can wrap up how you wish but I
would certainly like to thank everyone
that's come on the call here tonight
um all residents businesses that are out
there that are listening to this
certainly it will be available on a link
recording so it will reach many more
people through social media no doubt so
I would certainly like first and
foremost to thank all residents I would
certainly like to thank Anne
um Danielle Arthur Kathy for your time
tonight but I would particularly like to
thank you Tracy you are coordinating
this activity for Roger District Council
you have already done a splendid job and
you will continue I know to do a
splendid job so I want to thank you and
I also want to thank some of the
backroom people that aren't on screen
but have put this whole presentation
together tonight these things don't just
happen we don't just sort of get on a
zoom link there is preparation for it
and I really want to thank everyone for
everything that they're doing through
these difficult times let's let's be
honest they are difficult whether or not
you're an individual whether or not
you're a business
um and thank you very much indeed really
appreciate it
no thank you thank you councilor Overton
I think it just goes back to you know
we're all in this together and I know
that probably I'm not trying to be Pious
when I say that we are literally all in
this together we're out there
fact-finding and trying to support
everybody whilst living it ourselves but
I don't know if any of our panel want to
say anything in closing
um because I think we've come to the
kind of the end of the questions it was
one about windfall tax on it but we'll
pick that up outside I'm sure that will
be another letter that you can answer
the wooden but I'm sure we'll pick that
up as well but any anybody wants to to
make any closing comments before we
finish in four minutes
Kathy and then I'll come to councilor
Belton just very quickly to say that you
know if anybody is watching this either
live or being played back and they are
worried reach out for support it's what
we've been saying all along and it
doesn't matter really where you go to
reach out for this call but reach out to
somebody there are lots of organizations
out there
and fitness advice is just one of them
but you've got loads of links in the
chat so try and reach out and get some
help and support because as everyone
says we are all in this together yeah we
are and share this when it comes around
you know if you've got friends or or
neighbors only neighbors that can't you
know haven't been able to access this
this will be promoted out there for
people to use on slow time so take it to
your neighbors and have another a cup of
tea or coffee and a cake you never know
and watch it back but councilor Belton
thank you yeah just to reiterate that
there's there's lots of us out there
that people can reach out to in the
community whether that be through their
counselors through the voluntary through
the council itself everybody wants to
help and and wants to do something good
to to
um get through this tough time and to
reiterate Anne's point about the
Business Awards it's not all doom and
gloom at the moment we've got some
fantastic businesses in this District
that are doing great things and as they
continue to grow they offer employment
and it and it goes full circle so if you
know a good business if you are a good
business get them involved in the awards
it's completely free from end to end and
there'll be lots of good publicity for
anyone that enters and I think it's it's
important to recognize the good that's
going on as well at such a tough time
no brilliant thanks councilor Belton and
just to kind of sum up I've been in
local government for longer than I care
to mention
um but I will stop right there because
I'm still very passionate about it but I
see a little hand waving at me which was
councilor William so I'll bring him in
yeah thank you Tracy uh thank you for
this this evening it's been really
helpful
um I'm old enough to remember interest
rates of 16
I'm not sure if Simon does remember that
I suspect he does it we got through it
then we will get through it again so
it's it's not all do with Gloom and it
is bringing out the best in people so
thank you
yeah it really does and that was what I
was going to touch on in the sense that
you know yes we are a local Authority
but we we are
I'm very passionate about delivering
what's right and what's needed at the
point it's needed for our for our
residents and actually I'm not going to
sum up I'm going to allow Julie from Hub
at the mega Center because what she said
is perfect and she's put in the chair as
a community we're stronger together
and I I think I'll leave it there
because there's nothing more to be said
we are in this together and we will get
through it together
so please don't worry about this on your
own we're all there to support each
other so get in contact but have a
wonderful wonderful evening whatever
you're doing
and have a lovely lovely Christmas
I get to say it see I get to say it now
so yeah thank you very much for your
time have a wonderful Christmas and take
care of yourselves and your friends and
your neighbors and everybody else
so thank you thank you Tracy thank you
thanks bye-bye bye